David model McLeod UK Independence Party
you kept 208 Liam McKechnie Scottish
family party 197 kalmyk Nally Scottish
Labour Party 4849 Carolyn's gamja
Scottish Green Party 916 Joe Swanson
Scottish Liberal Democrats nineteen
thousand five hundred and twenty-three
[Applause]
hear the cheers that Joe Swinton we're
doing that so called big a potentially a
Macallan of borås joints and well in
terms of leaders you've gone that's the
second and one Nigel Dodds of
Westminster leaders the DUP s gone and
the SMP as you can see there I've taken
these Dunbartonshire Joe Swenson will no
longer be an MP well so many questions
being asked even during the campaign
about the nature of the Lib Dem campaign
well we'll talk about that an awful lot
more later but there we are
Joe Swenson is out of Parliament another
gain for the SNP what we knew
well I'd like to thank the returning
officer and all of the staff that have
been involved in this election campaign
the emergency services and all of my
fellow candidates and congratulate Amy
wholeheartedly it is an amazing job I'm
sure you will love doing it and I wish
you well and what you said about young
women and smashing boundaries I
wholeheartedly agree I would also like
to thank my agents Liberal Democrat
campaigners and activists who have made
this campaign special with the
additional challenge of doing it as
leader of the Liberal Democrats too I
particularly would like to thank my mom
my sister Nicola my husband Duncan and
our two darling boys Andrew and Gabriel
and I would like to thank the people of
Eastern Barton sure for putting your
faith in me for 12 and a half years to
represent this wonderful place I have
enjoyed serving our communities I've
enjoyed having the opportunity to make a
difference whether it's here on local
issues whether it's supporting people
working on the national minimum wage by
introducing penalties for rogue
employers whether it's women in our
economy by introducing gender pay gap
reporting tonight we have seen that it
is likely that Boris Johnson is on
course to get a majority and it is
clearly a good night for the SNP some
will be celebrating the wave of
nationalism that is sweeping on both
sides of the border and I do
congratulate all those who are newly
elected these are very significant
results for the future of our country
and I will be making further remarks
later today but let me say now for
millions of people in our country these
results will bring dread and dismay and
people are looking for hope
I still believe that we as a country can
be warm and generous inclusive and open
and that by working together with our
nearest neighbors we can achieve so much
more Liberal Democrats will continue to
stand up for these values that guide our
liberal movement openness fairness
inclusivity we will stand up for hope
[Applause]